I am really excited to be here not so
much because I get to present some
science that I'm very excited about but
I'm just really enthusiastic to see so
many great people here who are
interested in science and I'm gonna try
not to let you down and so the key I
think this talk precedes is if you have
a question stop me write if you don't
understand something stop me I'll try to
explain it I wanted to show you a little
bit of data today to give you a sense of
how us as scientists discover new things
to try to sort of reach in this case
reach back in time reach way back in
time to try to understand where biology
even came from now I was told that I
should maybe do a little bit of
introduction of myself to tell you where
this biological entity came from and so
I'll do that then give give you an
overview of the kind of science that
we're doing so as dr. zell mentioned i
was a student at the university of
wisconsin actually grew up in a very
tiny town well actually about eight
miles outside of a very tiny town in the
middle of Wisconsin and like many other
people from my home state I grew up on a
dairy farm and in fact I up until just a
few years ago I could say that I milked
cows for more years than I was doing
science ok so if you want to if you want
me to tell you how to milk a cow I'd be
happy to chat with you after after the
talk but I think it was it was that
experience on the farm and being
surrounded by biology and having a bit
of curiosity about exploring sort of
unexplored territory which made me
become a scientist and I think I think
one of the formative points in my life
was finding what we had we had a globe a
globe of the earth at home and it was a
very old globe
and I looked at this globe thinking wow
I want to be an explorer I'm gonna
explore parts of the globe that haven't
been explored before and I was really
disappointed to find that even on this
very old globe there was only a little
tiny part of that globe that that had
printed on it
unexplored territory the entire globe
had largely been explored by the way
that unexplored territory was at the
North Pole right so I don't know if I
was gonna go there but it is very clear
that there is a huge amount of
unexplored territory and in biological
sciences much of it tends to be very
very small very tiny in fact we tend to
work with a lot of molecules some of
them that we find in biology including
we find in human cells and others that
we can create by doing doing experiments
in the test tube basically we could even
evolve molecules in the test tube to do
things that perhaps are not present in
nature all right so we have enough
insight into biology to be able to
manipulate biology but what I think we
all would like to have as scientists is
a very clear sort of instruction list of
a parts list of all the biological parts
so that we can figure out really how
machines as complicated as humans work
and that's maybe the quest of a lot of
people who are doing science and in the
biological sciences at Yale we want that
parts list we want to understand what
those parts do we want to understand
them when they go wrong and we want to
fix them if they do go wrong all right
now I'm not going to talk about modern
medicine is as much as one might think
I'm going to have just a little bit of
information on how the science we do
relates to medicine but I want to tell
you about a time on the planet that we
call the RNA world all right this was a
time before there was DNA and before
there were proteins there's a very good
collection of data that says that
biology came from RNA that at one time
RNA molecules ruled the planet and
eventually those things evolve to give
rise to what we have today so in order
to introduce this story I got to tell
you what RNA
molecules are all right so what is RNA
well some of you oh you know here go
ahead
uh-huh I don't even know why I need
slides here today this is exactly right
so what you've described here is here is
DNA sorry
here is DNA let me see if I can get
myself a laser pointer here this is DNA
many of you know that DNA is a long
molecule and it's double-stranded so the
two strands wrap around each other all
right each human cell has about this
much DNA in it every one of your cells
you can't see your cells each one is so
small but it has a molecule or set of
molecules that together stretch about
the length of my arms all wrapped up
double-stranded and stuffed into each
cell and each one of those DNA molecules
codes for the entire instruction list
that tells your cells how to operate
most of that DNA codes for proteins
all right proteins are like the action
molecules of the cell DNA stores that
information so what is this RNA stuff
all right so RNA is one strand typically
one strand and the the budding
scientists in the audience noted that
there's a difference between RNA and DNA
and one of them is the the base here so
in this case this chemistry is slightly
different than this chemistry the one on
the Left called u or uracil is a bit
different than finding which is labeled
T here all right otherwise RNA and DNA
both have four bases and that's that big
ring structures the ring structures that
are shown here like these are the rings
and I have a little molecular model that
shows one what we call it in the RNA or
DNA chain right and so here is that ring
structure and in the center is little
molecule we call ribose if it's RNA that
little five little Pentagon structure in
this
we call that ribose in RNA and then
there's a third part which is phosphate
okay so this little molecule is one of
these units in the DNA or RNA chain now
there are billions of these in DNA in
every one of your cells right so if if
DNA if a link in that chain were this
big the DNA molecule and every one of
your cells would stretch to about the
coast of China right about halfway
around the around the earth of course
these molecules are very small we could
stuff them in these tiny cells that you
can't see RNA molecules are very similar
but there's one major difference other
than that you vs. T so again don't worry
too much about the details here this is
just a bunch of letters indicating the
different atoms in that in the chain
that is DNA or RNA RNA has an oxygen
here on this this little five membered
ring and DNA is lacking that oxygen
right so we call this ribose and since
there's a missing oxygen we call it
deoxy where it's missing oxygen ribose
deoxyribose ribose so that's where the
DNA the term DNA comes from is missing
that oxygen and it's missing that oxygen
on every sugar now I'll tell you why
biology uses DNA to store our
information because that DNA molecule
and it's missing oxygen are almost a
million times more stable all right so
if you're gonna store information right
if you're gonna keep information you
want to keep it for a long time you want
that molecule to be very stable RNA
falls apart very quickly but you know
again about a million times faster all
only because of that oxygen alright so
we stored information with DNA that DNA
codes for information that makes
proteins but what is puzzling about
modern cells is that they use RNA as a
go-between right so they have DNA but
they make RNA temporarily and then that
RNA tells the cell which proteins to
make that's a very odd arrangement it's
not clear at least initially wasn't
clear why biology has that RNA right in
the middle
between the two other important
molecules of the cell alright so let's
look at this because I'm going to tell
you that that RNA molecule or these RNA
molecules began life or life passed
through a phase where everything was run
by RNA you stored your information with
RNA and you did you you did chemistry
you acted in the cell with with RNA
structures and so I have to if I'm going
to tell you that RNA started like lakeil
early on in life I got to give you a
definition of life the problem is you
could act famous biologists what's the
definition of life and you'll probably
get 10 different answers that's kind of
embarrassing right I mean here we are
professional biologists and we don't
even have a good definite definition for
life so I'm gonna try I'm gonna I'm
going to show you my favorite mission of
life
so we need we need chemistry here that
it's capable of replication and
evolution basically it says you're going
to be reproduce or the biological
organism can make babies rights as
simple as that and over time the the
genetic information that's passed on can
change or the organism can evolve over
time so it's got an organism has to be
capable of reproduction and evolution
now but I want you guys to think about
this all of you think carefully about
this you can imagine some really
interesting gray areas where something
you say okay that's clearly alive right
do you see a fuzzy bunny rabbit bouncing
around okay that's alive but there are
other things that act like life in some
way and I want you to ask whether that
might be alive or not all right so
here's an example
so can you imagine I'd see some people
shaking no way they're not alive but
what would happen if a spaceship landed
outside and out came some robots that
began to pick up cars you melt down the
metal and make more robots and pretty
soon we were getting in the way and they
decided that they wanted to get rid of
us I mean I don't know do you call it a
robot do you call that a metal life-form
alright so I think that there's some
interesting gray areas for you to think
about another one
what about computer viruses they
replicate I think most biologists would
say no these are not alive but you can
imagine some really interesting things
that might shape your alright there's
some other questions that biologists ask
but I want to ask this last one what
about an individual molecule what about
something like this or something like
this with maybe a hundred of these links
stitched together what if that RNA
molecule could fold up do chemistry and
that chemistry that it did was to make
copies of itself it would be able to
make molecular babies right it's
sometimes it would make mistakes and
those molecules then could evolve right
that simple molecule looks nothing like
what we are today but but fits that
definition of life alright so let's look
at something that we would clearly say
is not alive it's kind of lifelike but
it's not alive and the one I chose here
is sodium chloride
like that's table salt it just has
crystals of salt you sprinkle this on
your food if you want it more salty
alright so what is it so the chemists
out there you'll know that table salt is
just sodium and chloride and sodium
plants are positive in charge chlorides
negative right the to attract and since
they attract did you get lots of them
attracting you can have sodium molecules
here actually form large crystals and
that's you see the crystals here all
right so let's take a look at their
properties all right here's some just a
picture of some crystals of salt we know
that all crystals can grow because if
you put Cristal crystals in a
very concentrated solution of sodium
chloride the crystals get bigger the
crystals grow alright they can reproduce
because you can take a salt crystal you
could crunch it up into thousands of
tiny salt crystals and put them in a
high salt solution and they will grow
they'll get better so now you have the
thousand salt crystals all right but
they can't evolve right so the way I
like to look at this is that if you had
two planets two new planets that you
discovered and you knew both of them had
some salty ocean and you sent two
Rockets up one rocket had a bagful of
salt and that rocket crashed into that
the first planets ocean and spread salt
crystals around if you came back four
billion years later and looked you'd
have a whole bunch of salt crystals
right nothing's really changed but if a
nut in the other rocket you shot it up
and you landed in the other salty ocean
on the other planet and that and that
rocket had molecules like this in it RNA
molecules that could fold up and make
babies you could wait for billion years
and you don't even have to go there
those creatures that evolved out of that
ocean are gonna come to visit you all
right they're gonna build rockets and
they're gonna come to visit you all
right so that in a sense is the
difference between things that look like
life and things that really can can
evolve and expand and do quite amazing
things if you give them enough time all
right now I gotta convince you of this
fact here and that is that all
life-forms on this planet are related
that early organism had DNA it had RNA
and it had proteins why do we know that
because all life on the planet no matter
how bizarre no matter how distant
related it is to us have all of those
components in place suggesting that our
our ancestor the the ancestor that gave
rise to all three of the domains of life
and I'll show you the domains of life in
a moment that they had those same
components so let's take a look at some
of the things that you can look at to
determine that that's true for example
all these proteins that we have by the
way these proteins again are the action
molecules in the cells they're doing a
lot of the chemistry that we need to be
alive all those proteins no matter what
organism you are we're using 20 of the
common same amino acids we all use the
same xx there is effectively an infinite
number of amino acids that you that
biology could have used but we're only
using the same xx implying that there
was an organism a long time ago that
decided that xx was the the the number
to use and they were gonna use 20 and we
have all benefited from that we were all
derived from that organism we still use
the same 20 amino acids to the
instruction list to make new proteins is
the same that that that instruction list
that code is the same in all organisms
on the planet there are coenzymes I'm
going to tell you about coenzymes and
how that relates to this little bottle
right here and I'm gonna say that that
when I get to this I'll stress this
again that all organisms on the planet
use coenzymes that are identical and
that we drive benefit this is a bottle
of vitamins we derive benefit from those
compounds and I'll tell you why that's
important but the last thing versatile
energy currency of all biology ATP
okay so what is ATP ATP is this molecule
here or this one here right this is a
this compound here in this model is
actually ATP
all right it's got that bass it's got
that sugar this little five membered
ring here and then these three
phosphates all right so isn't this
interesting all biology on the planet
uses that thing to store and to deliver
energy in to do almost all biological
processes and it's an RNA molecule right
we can see it's an RNA molecule it's got
that oxygen here in this sugar all right
so this is a universal energy currency
and it's made of RNA and the argument
here and I'll say this again multiple
times
why would biology choose an RNA molecule
to store energy in all domains of life
and every life-form
unless RNA came first and it had to
invent a way to store energy and all it
had to work with was an RNA all right
now there are other reasons why we know
life is related and that is that you can
look at modern organisms and you can
track mutations and so you can recognize
when an organism is closely related to
us just by examining it physically and
then you look at the genes and it turns
out that our genes are actually closely
related if you're far away if you're
very distantly related and you can tell
again by looking at the physical
attributes of the organisms then you're
you have more mutations separating you
and in a sense you can use the number of
mutations to determine how distantly
related an organism is but no matter how
distant they are all of us use very
similar components to do some of those
fundamental things that a cell needs to
do and those components are shared
amongst all life-forms whether you're a
human or whether you're a plant or
whether you're a bacterium we have some
components that are identical or shared
and are very similar alright so what you
might be surprised by
okay I could have used any buddies
picture here you be surprised that
chimps and humans which we know are
closely related because we can tell from
a physical form that they're closely
related we actually differ by only about
96 percent in our genes
so we're genetically almost identical to
chimps um you look around the room and
you may look around say wow people
around me look very different than I do
but you're almost genetically identical
to the person sitting right next to you
okay as you get further away we're less
similar now I want to show you the
family tree not your family tree but our
family tree all right so here's humans
our closest relatives are chimps and
bonobos and this little this is like our
family tree the distance the length of
these lines indicate how closely related
we are we shared an ancestor between
humans these two animals at this point
here and then later on those organisms
split and so they're more closely
related to each other because these
lines are closer here all right here's
gorillas we're further related right
they're more distantly related here's a
ranga Tang and I'm not sure I know what
that is but it's a little bit further
away than this one right so that's our
close family tree now I'm going to
impress upon you that life on the planet
is amazingly diverse there are organisms
that are amazingly distant from us and
yet we share a lot of the same
components that make our cells run so
here are here this I actually think this
is one of the most amazing figures that
biologists have produced this is the the
entire tree of life right there are many
organisms on here some of them you can't
read because their scientific names and
and I'm not sure I know why scientists
use scientific names because no one can
really figure out easily what they mean
but let me tell you I'm going to tell
you three things there are two things
there are three domains of life here
archaeans I'm sorry here are eukaryotes
here archaeans and here are back
now you might have heard of bacteria
right we're eukaryotes and then this is
a domain of life that was discovered not
that long ago only a couple of decades
ago they live in strange places they
typically live in the ocean or it at
places that are very high in temperature
like thermal vents at the bottom of the
ocean they're very strange creatures but
it turns out that if you look at this
tree just like the the chimp versus
human tree you can see that these
organisms have sort of about halfway
distance between bacteria and eukaryotes
now where are we on this list
we're Homo sapiens Homo sapiens is right
here so we're at the very tip of this
branch of the tree all right so there's
people now what is Xia
anybody know what Xia is anybody know
what Xia is yes Xue yeah you know what
in a sense you're right okay you hang
hang on to that idea and it'll be clear
how close you are to the right answer
yes
it's corn all right
on this scale of this map of life the
closest thing mapped on here is corn now
that doesn't mean that our closest
relative is corn it just means that
there's an entire zoo of organisms that
are all at this little tip anybody know
what capricious is there will be no one
who will know what comprenez is yes go
ahead mushrooms these are fungi yes
those are mushrooms all right now if you
go to a zoo okay or you go to a
Botanical Garden everything that you can
see with the naked eye largely is
sitting right at this little tip of the
Tree of Life there is a massive amount
of life that you would never see unless
you are interested in biology in general
all the concerns that we have typically
in terms of medicine are with people or
our food or maybe a few things up here
that infect us right there's its giant
tree of life now there's a problem here
and that there's no start to this tree
where is the root
okay well the root is hidden right here
and that's that organism somewhat back
in time there's an organism that gave
rise to all three of those domains and
it has DNA and it has RNA and it has
proteins but that combination is too
complicated for it to have arise arisen
spontaneously
all right so how did it come about well
we think that there was something that
was before this tree that this tree was
somehow rooted in an RNA world this is
before there were proteins before there
was DNA only RNA world molecules and RNA
world creatures all right now I'm gonna
try to convince you that that's true but
I got to give you a sense of how long
ago this was and how we actually
discover evidence for an RNA world all
right so let's look at them time here
the origin of life how long ago well we
know from geological data that the earth
formed about four-and-a-half billion
years ago okay that's a long time ago
when did life occur well we know that
there's evidence that there were
probably complex we call microbial mats
this really means slime right there were
slime mats of bacteria or small
single-celled organisms about 3 and 1/2
billion years ago right so this is a is
a hands holding what really is
biological slime little organisms that
are living in a mat now so so we don't
we don't know exactly when life began
but it had to begin somewhere after
four-and-a-half billion years ago right
because the planet wasn't here otherwise
or significantly before three and a
billion to give rise to organisms that
could live in these big communities and
make these mats
so we think probably about four billion
years ago all right so let me give you a
sense of how long ago that was all right
so here's today exactly as we're sitting
here this is today and if you go back on
this line this is like going back in
time if you go back about 65 million
years ago you get to the extinction of
the dinosaurs right so imagine that the
length of that line represented 65
million years when the humans come on
them on the scene
well hominids our early ancestors came
about only just several million years
ago very very short time compared to the
extinction of dinosaurs all right now
what about the origin of life oh so
first of all why do we know how do we
know this we can we can look at fossils
right actual file you go to the Peabody
Museum and see things like this fossil
hominids or fossil dinosaurs so we can
date when those things occurred and we
know a lot about them from their fossils
okay so how do we get at original life
well turns out that molecules like this
don't leave a whole lot of fossils all
right you can't go and dig into the dirt
find fossils of the earliest RNA
entities so we got to do something
different all right now let me give you
a sense of the time that's elapsed to
show you how really impossible this
problem is now in the in the previous
figure I showed you that very top line
that one line here is 65 million years
there's this extinction of dinosaurs and
there's today so if you go back another
65 million and another 65 million and
another 65 million in another or so you
get to the point at which reptiles you
go another hundred and twenty or hundred
and fifty million years you get the
emergence of land plants so everything
we know and see and love about the world
in its biological diversity we see only
developing a very short time ago if you
go way back in time a billion two
billion three billion about three and a
half billion you have things like these
microbial mass
and then you go further back probably
another half a billion years or so to
four billion you have the origin of life
all right so you might think that our
task is impossible how are we gonna find
four life forms or how we gonna worry
about life forms that have emerged on
the planet so long ago and that have
long since been driven to extinction
right modern the modern world is
dominated by organisms like us DNA RNA
and protein organisms the RNA world
organisms are all gone however I'm going
to tell you that there are traces of
them with us today because we can't see
fossils in the way that you would seem
at the Peabody Museum but we can find
molecular fossils and I'm gonna show you
some of those things well we can look
for those molecular fossils in our own
genes and what's that that's because
every time a biological entity
reproduces it passes on genetic
information from one organism to the
next right and then as time goes on that
organism reproduces you pass on the
genetic information anything in those
genes that's really important for the
organism to survive will be preserved
and if it was really important for
billion years ago and it's important now
you will can see traces of those
molecules in our cells today all right
so I'm gonna show you one of the most
amazing molecular fossils from a time
when biology was transitioning from an
all RNA world into an RNA world that
also made proteins all right so let me I
gotta set the stage here so again modern
cells use DNA and they make more DNA
with a protein called
DNA polymerase simply a protein it goes
out and copies DNA all right so when our
cells divide we have to make more DNA
that DNA codes for messenger RNAs rnase
that take messages to a machine to make
proteins right so that RNA is made by
another protein called RNA polymerase
copies DNA but converts it into RNA and
then the RNA is used to code for protein
right this is the instruction list that
tells the cell what proteins to make
ribosomes are the machines that make
proteins okay but what do they look like
well here's of those big machines all
right
see the blue squiggles and the gray
squiggles that those are big RNA
molecules right one of them well both of
them together are built from thousands
of these nucleotides strung together in
long and to long chains the little
purple squiggles are proteins that are
kind of helping the system right but if
you look at the very core it's right in
the center here of this big machine that
makes proteins it's all RNA in other
words the machine the biological machine
in all of our cells that makes proteins
is an RNA machine right so the the
chemists that makes proteins in our
cells by the way and proteins are
usually the chemists it's not a protein
that makes proteins it's an RNA that
makes proteins and so you can imagine
this why on earth would biology choose
to make all the catalysts all all the
chemists on the planet using an RNA
chemist this is really what's going on
you have a very special RNA that's
making all these proteins that then go
off and do a whole bunch of other
chemistry
unless RNA came first and RNA invented
proteins all right so this big wonderful
machine which its structure was
determined at Yale University and won
Tom Stites a Nobel Prize that big
machine is an RNA machine at its core
all right so it was it was data like
this it was evidence like this that
began to get scientists interested in
the possibility that RNA once ruled the
planet and there was a few people I want
to note that were very instrumental in
telling this so it's a sort of
describing this to the world of science
one of them is a guy by the name of Carl
Woese Carl was a graduate student at
Yale University he did his training at
Yale and he went off to become a
professor at the University of Illinois
and he was puzzling over how proteins
are made
and how the genetic code came to be and
the only way he could answer that is he
said gee if RNA could do chemistry if
RNA could be a chemist then perhaps you
could imagine in a very easy way in
which biology could come to be you
didn't need proteins
you didn't need DNA that RNA could do
the chemistry all right so he was the
first one to say this in a book titled
the genetic code by the way this is a
book that's hard to get now if you find
a copy if you see that book anywhere at
a book store or someplace where you can
get a cheap buy it because it's probably
worth about two hundred dollars now you
can sell it on eBay I might even buy it
from you if you have a copy all right
now there's a couple of other names I
want to mention one it's Tom check the
others Sid Altman so dr. Altman is a
Yale professor to this day right he won
the Nobel Prize along with Tom Cech in
1989 why because they had the first
examples of RNA molecules this is RNA
called RNA speed right so this RNA goes
out finds another Arnim eight RNA and
cuts it in fact it does that cutting
reaction about a billion times faster
than if you just sat there and watch
that RNA it's not going to break apart
fairly stable in comes RNA Spee comes in
cuts that Arnie about a billion times
faster and that cutting event is
important to have this other RNA the
second RNA work
so here is a very complex RNA structure
that is able to fold up and act as a
really good catalyst chemist in a Cell
and that is important ultimately for
cells to make proteins again another bit
of evidence that suggests that RNA came
before proteins right now I want to tell
you about some RNAs that we're finding
now and we call these things ribose
switches ribose or ribose and switches
because they're gonna work as as genetic
switches they're gonna turn genes on and
off and I'm gonna tell you right now
that these things are very common in
bacterial cells and and and it cells
from some other organisms and they look
like they look exactly like what you
would have expected RNAs to look like in
an RNA world so what does a ribose which
well here's one of these messages right
so this is one of these long rnas and
the black part here codes for protein
that's gonna make protein but in many
modern cells there's little fragments
little tails and heads of these RNAs
that people thought were junk this is
just junk biologies accidentally put
this here and it doesn't matter well it
turns out that in many organisms there's
not much genetic junk at all that we
just didn't know what it did okay
so here's an example of an RNA so this
whole thing is RNA but it's this end
that folds into one of these complex
structures and it has a function in this
case it's going to go it's going to bind
to something it's going to grab
something and it's going to turn the
production of that protein on or off
it's gonna act as a genetic switch just
like a light switch so I'm going to show
you some examples I'm gonna try to give
you a sense of why these things look
like they crawled out of an RNA world
alright so here this is a little bit
complicated but I wanted to show you
some real data so this is a cartoon of
one of these RNA molecules so this
little model see there's a little letter
A there that a indicates that this
molecule is at that position in the RNA
chain this
this fairly complicated molecule errs at
that position and it's colored red
because we we can find many thousands of
these RNAs in many different bacteria no
matter how distant really related they
are and they always have an a at that
spot alright and that a is important for
this switch to work and you can look at
all all around here when you see red
those are highly constant right no
matter what bug you pull it from it's
got that nucleotide there that suggests
that the that those sequences those
nucleotides that those positions are
super important for the RNA to function
they're important for the RNA to
function today and they were probably
important for billion years ago when
these RNAs were doing basically the same
thing in primitive cells all right so
that RNA binds this compound that
compounds very scary but if you take
vitamin pills you're taking you're
ingesting you're eating that compound
every time you take a vitamin pill right
because that compound is called vitamin
b12 or it's actually coenzyme b12 it's a
slight derivative of vitamin b12 but you
take vitamin b12 your cells take it up
you convert it into this compound and
you do all sorts of chemical reactions
with it in your body it's essential if
you don't have vitamin b12 you will die
okay
it turns out that bacteria are the same
way so are plants so are those crazy
archaeans I talked about everybody needs
b12 and there's this wonderful fillet
that folds into this complex shape and
right in the middle of this thing is b12
so there are lots of these kinds of
switches in in in cells that will sense
this compound and they're not made of
protein they're made of RNA now what's
interesting about this is that if you
look at b12 if you look at its chemical
structure so this is the same as this
one over here but I've circled parts
that look like RNA in fact again that
part on the top is exactly this molecule
alright so this is this important
molecule that we need to survive and it
has a chunk of RNA on it all life on the
planet exploits this molecule
essentially all life suggesting that
this compound is very very old
probably was invented in the RNA world
is still used by modern cells today and
in some cases is sensed by an RNA
molecule all right are there others well
here's some more RNAs they fold into
this shape they bind that compound that
compound is called Sam and Sam has this
same chemical group on it all right
again it's these are compounds that are
essential for life on the planet
here's another RNA it binds a compound
very similar to Sam called SAH there's
another RNA component
here's another ribose which by the way
this compound is a derivative of
riboflavin again in this bottle of pills
here and the whole thing is made from
RNA here's another one we call this
compound moco molybdenum cofactor or
moco that thing is made from RNA here's
another one
tetrahydrofolate this whole thing is
part here is made from a nucleotide much
like this derived from RNA all right and
in each case as a wonderful RNA
structure that binds in this case that
binds two of these molecules and turns
gene expression on and off here's
another one this is a derivatives but
when you're making these compounds there
are intermediates and here's an RNA that
binds one of those intermediates again a
bit a chunk of RNA the RNA world
I like these in particular because many
bacteria have the need to tell cells
tell their cells what to do at certain
times they have little signaling
molecules we call them second messengers
all right so these little messenger
molecules many bacteria are made from
RNA this is just a little RNA the whole
thing is one chunk of RNA and yet there
are RNAs out there that sense them and
turn genes on and off alright I can go
on and on I'm going to skip go I want to
show you this one here again this one is
in this bottle of pills this is a
derivative of thiamine the vitamin
thiamine and that top part is is made in
the same way that you make these RNA
molecules now why I wanted to show you
this one
it's because you can ask okay what you
know these what are these Yale
scientists working on life that might
have been around four billion years ago
who cares about this stuff all right so
we wanted to learn a little bit about
where life came from and sometimes you
make advances in the lab that might help
humans might be useful for treating
human disease and so I want to show you
this this RNA thiamine or thiamine
pyrophosphate in this RNA okay so when
we first started discovering these RNAs
I would go to two audiences of
scientists and I would say okay here's
what we know and then I would say gee I
think these should make good targets for
new medicines so imagine that you had a
bacterial infection and if that bacteria
used this RNA to see that compound to do
important things right if you could
trick that RNA you can make a compound
that tricked this RNA into binding the
the drug the the end limb to say was an
antibiotic and not the normal compound
that you could kill the cells and save
the person who's infected all right so
we we thought that this was going to be
a useful thing to do but then I would
get this question from other scientists
by the way if you don't know this
scientists like to to fight argue with
each other about all these kinds of
ideas and I would always get a scientist
in the audience who would say well you
know come on dr. breaker if this is a
good idea if you could make antibiotics
that hit these RNAs you would know that
some drug company would have already
made a compound that would hit that RNA
and we'd be using these as treatments
for humans already and I would say yeah
you know I know you're right
but it sure makes sense to us that there
should be you should be able to to trick
these RNAs and save people and we now
know that in fact scientists had
encountered compounds that hit these
RNAs and in fact I'll just to jump to
one of them here so this is the normal
compound that this RNA binds this one
here is a compound called Pyrrha
Thiemann it was made in 1942 right right
in the middle of World War two and this
pound which is just a little different
right this little center ring is
different than the ring here okay
scientists knew that this killed
bacteria all the way back to 1942 and
they had no idea how it worked well we
now know that that compound sits right
in here this little purplish structure
here right and the phosphates are
binding here this ring structure on the
left hand side is binding on the right
hand side of this here and then this
part is that ring right here and the RNA
doesn't care about the ring it only
binds the two sides it doesn't care
about the center and we wouldn't have
discovered these RNAs if we hadn't been
thinking about how life began all right
so can we find more right are there more
of these relics you know hidden in our
genomes hidden in our DNA that we could
I'm gonna tell you just very briefly how
we find them so many of you will know
that that DNA stores our genetic
information so there are genes in
different places in our in our genome
but sometimes there are gaps there's a
string of DNA that doesn't seem to do
anything right memory this is junk this
idea of junk DNA well again we don't
think that there's a whole lot of junk
in many stretches of DNA so we look in
these regions we look here in these gaps
to try to find new RNAs that are that
until this point are undiscovered so
what do we need to do this we need DNA
sequence we need Yale's supercomputer
capability and outcomes wonderful RNA
structures and sequences that have
functions that are completely unknown
and we want to figure out what they do
so let me show you some of these
sometimes we find things like this again
remember the red the red letters are
very conserved we tend not to be
interested in these because they they
appear to be binding to proteins so
these so if your binding to proteins
chances are you might be a more recent
evolutionary invention we want to find
the things that might be very primitive
so we ignore those
and I'm gonna tell you a little bit
about this because it is a ribose which
it's one of the most interesting rival
such as we found now in some cases and I
won't talk about this but in some cases
we find RNAs that are really big and we
don't know what they do so this is one
of those that's really big that RNA is
big I know it's big because I made this
slide and I made it kind of tricky that
is a big RNA biology right so usually
they're quite small this thing is
enormous and we know that it's a very
intricately folded RNA so for those of
you who know a little bit about how
these RNAs might fold we know things
like this like those two nucleotides
here reach way over and interact with
those two nucleotides way over here and
that's over and over again these
interact way down here by these this RNA
is fully into some giant RNA complex and
we have no idea what it does alright now
we've figured out one of these other
ones we figure out this one alright so
now you can play sort of budding
microbiologist here let's say I tell you
here is an RNA we don't know what does
we think it's a switch but we don't know
what it does and if I told you that
these are the twelve most common genes
that are hanging around this RNA well
sometimes we say all right here's a
mystery RNA and here's a gene if we know
what that gene codes for you know let's
say that gene codes to make one of those
vitamins well then maybe the RNA senses
that vitamin alright but here are some
genes and don't worry about the names
because and we know a lot about this
kind of stuff we had no clue from those
genes what that RNA was doing
we just we didn't know enough about
those genes we didn't know enough about
the the possible molecules or ions that
might be sensed by the RNA to tell
there's a question back here yes
what's sorry what's the Kim you mean of
the big molecule the vitamin b12 or of
this big RNA yeah so that that molecule
it made only the four nucleotides
it has about 850 nucleotides but they're
just reusing this one and the other
three that are from RNA it's only made
of RNA right it's just a base about 850
that's an unusually large RNA come you
know compared to what we find in modern
cells but it's only pure RNA and then
sometimes in rare cases happy accidents
have testing ideas we've had some ideas
about what it might might do or some
really bad ideas about what it might do
and we were testing those ideas and we
found that there was a contamination in
one of the chemicals we were testing and
that contamination triggered the RNA to
switch and that contamination is
something that you guys probably use
every day right so this is toothpaste
all right what do you guys know is that
what's the most famous thing in
toothpaste
I heard fluoride out there somewhere
fluoride so the contamination in our
sample was fluoride and that told us
what the switch was working with all
right so Florida was a contamination and
what we did then to prove that that RNA
sensed fluoride was we put the RNA so
now we're doing a little genetic
engineering we put the RNA on protein
that turns blue when it's made right so
here's our RNA we attach it to a region
that'll code this this fancy name thing
it just means that the proteins gonna
turn blue when it's made and then we put
those in cells and we add fluoride
sodium fluoride this is no fluoride the
cells are not blue and as we add more
and more fluoride the cells turn blue
all right so this is a little genetic
switch that binds fluoride the ion
fluoride right now you guys might not
know this some of you might know what
millimolar is just note that this 30
here that 30 is about two to three times
lower in concentration than the fluoride
in your toothpaste okay so this
toothpaste could turn on that genetic
switch right when you brush there are
bacteria on your teeth that are saying
oh my god there's a lot of fluoride I'm
turning on this switch and the reason
why it does it is that fluoride is toxic
to most cells okay but I'm gonna argue
that fluoride has been around for a long
time it's been around since the
formation of the earth and that biology
has hated fluoride for a long time but
it has mechanisms including things like
that RNA switch to sense fluoride and to
overcome whatever toxic effects fluoride
might have now I want to show you how
this RNA does oh I have to prove that
this is indeed what biology cares about
so we were doubting this I mean why
would RNA wanna bind
why does biology care about it and we
found an organism it has this crazy name
methyl Oh bacterium X torque ins this
bacterium has 10 of these RNAs when most
cells only have one or maybe two of
these RNAs all right so we knew there
was gonna be something that was gonna be
famous about this bug that told us what
the real compounder Ligon was for this
for this RNA so this thing has ten most
have only one or two so this microbe is
famous it's famous for each compounds
like this or compounds like this right
there's fluorine on here so when these
organisms are eating these organic
compounds and by the way this organism
was found at a chemical spill site right
so there's a industrial accident
chemicals were in the environment and
and there were microbes there eating
those nasty chemicals with chloride or
chlorine or fluorine fluoride is toxic
the
sells these microbes had figured out a
way to sense fluoride and say oops I
better stop eating because the more I
eat the more fluoride I release and the
sicker I'm going to be okay so we knew
when we found this bug that indeed that
was exactly what this thing was doing
now I'm going to show you a picture of
exactly how this RNA binds fluoride so
here's this crazy shaped RNA I'll tell
you right now that the red dot right
here is fluoride and the way this RNA
captures fluoride is it builds a little
magnesium cage so magnesium is
positively charged fluoride is negative
so it builds a little positive charge
cage and holds fluoride in the center
okay and I'll show you a blow-up of the
structure again there's fluoride those
three blue circles are magnesium and
those magnesium's are held together by
phosphates the little tail of this
molecule it's held together by these
phosphates now what I like about this is
that this little part here reminds me a
lot of this floor appetizer you can see
this in the Peabody Museum it's a it's
one of these gemstones that you would
see at the Peabody this same material is
the material that that it really forms
enamel on your teeth and the reason why
you brush with fluoride is you want to
make that enamel as hard as you can to
prevent bacteria from drilling holes in
your teeth
but fluoride also inhibits the cells
from growing it stops the cells from
growing okay and that's why you brush to
harden your enamel but also to slow
those microbes down and those microbes
are fart they're fighting back with an
RNA world contraption this little Ryba
switch that senses fluoride and tells
the cell hey you better turn on some
genes to overcome fluoride toxicity all
right now I'm going to show you one last
slide to tell you how close scientists
are to really understanding the earliest
days of the RNA world so this is
scientists attempt
- roll back the clock four billion years
all right so remember the definition of
life a self-sustaining chemical process
that it's capable of replication and
evolution and I said that may be a
molecule one molecule could do that and
that would be a molecule RNA that is
able to fold up and make babies it's got
to fold up and reproduce so RNA needs to
make RNA and that would be a living
molecule so how close are scientists to
recreating something that probably went
extinct three and a half or four billion
years ago all right now this again I
apologize for all the letters squiggles
here but this is a really special RNA
here on the right hand side that RNA
molecule has the ability to fold up it
grabs two other RNAs there's a little
short RNA and here's a longer RNA it
grabs those two and it can start adding
nucleotides on the end it can grow that
third RNA that this top RNA can grow it
in size and the way it grows it is it
uses this other RNA to tell it what
nucleotides to add in other words it has
the ability to transfer information from
one RNA to another it can copy it make
it longer and that's the act of
reproducing if you're an RNA molecule
alright so how good is that RNA so here
this one this one might make you go
blind if you look at it too long here
but let me tell you what's going on that
little RNA is this little blob right
here and this this is a method it's a
scientific method by which we can
separate RNA molecules based on size so
really short RNA czar at the bottom and
really law pays our way at the top
alright so what this RNA is doing is
it's grabbing this it's adding
nucleotides all the way along here and
what is it there's there's three six
nine there's 11 nucleotides here if you
look here this RNA is going to be made
longer by one two three four five six
seven eight
910 and maybe 11 right there all right
so this RNA can extend another RNA by
about 11 nucleotides now if you give it
two of these sequences so you have this
one and another one that's not shown
here if it has two of those sequences
then you go 22 nucleotides if you give
it three it goes up by about 33
nucleotides 4 5 6 etc all the way up you
can see there's big long rnas being made
here there's over 200 nucleotides that
this RNA can add to another RNA all
right 200 nucleons is more than the size
of the RNA that's making RNA in other
words this is an RNA that has the
ability make other RNAs as long as it is
or even longer if scientists can only
teach that on how to make copies of
itself you will have the reinvention of
a living molecule probably for the first
time in 4 billion years that day will
happen it will probably happen sooo soon
we will all be alive it happens because
I think it's going to happen that soon
and that's again a really special moment
because you can think about what might
have happened four billion years ago you
can collect evidence for it in cells
like ours and then you can devise
experiments to recreate what might have
happened that long ago okay so I think
that there's a it's sort of very
exciting times for us because we can we
can sort of peer back and see what might
have happened billions of years ago but
in some ways we can also exploit our new
knowledge to create things like new
medicines new antibiotics I'm going to
end there and just show you a picture of
the faces that actually do this work I
want you guys to know I won't name names
here but I want you to know that the
people who do work like what I described
are closer to your age
than they are to my age very young
people are doing science that I think is
very important to understand how biology
works where it came from
and where we're taking it into the
future